مشهد يطلق عليه اسم انتصار مدينه تطلبت
224 يوما من الصراع المحتدم بين فاجنر
والقوات الاوكرانيه ليرفع الروس علامه نصر
بارد بطعم خساره كل ما في المدينه
لكن الانتصار المفترض ياتي في ظل صوره
رماديه ونزاع على تبني الانجاز وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه كتبت كلمه النهايه على
احدى اطول معارك الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا باعلانها السيطره التامه على
مدينه ضخمه من قبل قوه فاغنر
على اثر الاعمال الهجوميه لوحدات فاغنر
بدعم من مدفعيه وحده وطيرانها اكتمل تحديد
مدينه ارتيموفسكي
عمل يستحق الشكر من قبل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذي هنا الوحدات المقاتله
وقوات الجيش التي قدمت الدعم لها بحسب
وصفه شكرا قد لا يبدو ذا اهميه بالنسبه لي
الذي اشار الى جهد فاجنر المتفرد في
المعركه مصنفا للجيش الروسي الى فئتين
يحترم الاولى منها لما قدمته من دعم شحيح
واخرى وصفها بالمشلوله على حد تعبيره
استغرقت العمليه للسيطره على باخموت 224
يوما فاجنر وحدها كانت هنا
وبينما يتقاسم الروس اسباب النصر واطرافه
تنكر كيا بالسيطره الروسيه على المدينه
بالاصل
اعلان بريكوجي السيطره على بخموت ليس الا
وسيله يغطي بها حجم الخسائر التي طالت
قواته
وبالرغم من تصريحات
في قمه مجموعه السبع والتي تعكس واقع
الخساره في بخمت الا ان مسؤولين اوكران
يصرون على ان وحدات الجيش تحاصر المدينه
بشكل شبه دائري
لم يتبقى شيء هناك باخ متباقيه في قلوبنا
تضارب في التصريحات من طرفي الحرب يوحي
بان الواقع قد يكون انقلابا للادوار بين
من يوجد داخل المدينه ومن يحاصرها واذ
كانت معركه ضخمه مشكوكا في اهميتها
الاستراتيجيه ستصبح نهايتها ايضا مشكوكا
عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات